I want to watch this movie.
I changed my mind make this one.
Charlie Day versus the Rescuers.
I'm into it.
The Rescuers visit Philadelphia.
Execs night of the director.
Yeah.
I love this.
Nina.
What's the worst movie that they can remake
as a live action film?
Thanks for asking Brian.
I have a little trouble settling on one because
so many of the things I thought were terrible
ideas have either already happened or are
in production.
So, that's unsettling.
And I should also say that I have seen several
of the live action remakes and I'm across
the board not a fan.
So that's where I'm coming from as an audience
member.
Sure.
Understand.
And I thought a lot about my least favorite,
which was the Beauty and the Beast adaptation,
which had a number of problems, including
like girl boss Belle and the idea that every
single thing in the castle was alive which-
So girl boss Belle, you mean the pandering
way in which they were like, she's in the
science and then it doesn't come into play
at all ever.
And also there's a whole subplot where she
gets in trouble for teaching a young girl
to read, even though young children literacy
was very championed in France at the time
when this film is set.
So it doesn't work.
Got it.
But, I was thinking about some of the more
unsettling parts of that film.
And I think anyone who has seen that movie
knows how creepy the beast looks for the entire
movie until he turns back into Downton Abbey,
Stan Stevens.
Mm-mm.
And in that vein, I was thinking about how
horrifying it would be if Lilo and Stitch
were adapted into a live action remake and
we had to look at a fully realized CGI Stitch.
Oh no.
I thought they are making that one.
I checked, I could be wrong.
Okay.
You checked I didn't, so you would know better
than me.
I don't want to see that.
In the immortal words of Lisa Kudrow in The
Comeback.
I don't want to see that.
You don't want to see a cute little CGI Stitch
boy?
They don't make anything cute in these live
action remakes.
All the lions in The Lion King were horrifying
too.
And that's a real animal that exists, not
an alien that's adorably creepy, but weird
objectively in cartoon form.
Specifically creepy.
I don't want to see Andy Serkis in a motion
capture suit in Lilo and Stitch.
That's not true.
I do not need that kind of energy in my life.
Actually you know what?
Maybe I would only like it if it was Andy
Serkis, but it probably won't be.
So I still don't want to see it.
I would love it if it was Andy Serkis, but
they never animated over it.
If it was just this middle aged man in a unitard
that a child is raising as a pet.
Like the movie Walk Like A Man from the 80s,
starting Howie Mandel and Christopher Lloyd?
I would watch that, but you know that's not what
would come of this.
It would just be like an uncanny valley nightmare
causing instrument of chaos.
Brian, you had a rebuttal.
Yes.
I do Have a rebuttal.
I don't think you're wrong because they would
do a CGI situation.
But what if look behind you, to your, I don't
know which direction it is because Zoom is
weird, but yeah, that one.
Who do you see behind you?
Baby Yoda?
The love of my life, baby Yoda.
Practical effect.
What if they made a Stitch that's a practical
effect.
That's adorable.
That's animatronic.
Sure.
That's got a person's hand in it doing this.
Okay.
Counterpoint, Baby Yoda just sits around and just
makes cooing baby noises.
Stitch has a very active presence.
He doesn't do a lot of action scenes.
He doesn't do a lot of movement.
He waddles and he goes like this and he makes
cute baby noises and eats cookies.
He eats soup.
Yeah.
Yeah. You're right.
Just really, really quick point of interest
just because I can already hear people smashing
their keyboards to death.
I do think it's important to point out the
baby Yoda does have a real name and that it's
Stephen Merchant Yoda.
Kroger's Stephen Merchant Yoda.
He's named for his godfather.
Read the lore.
I remember.
I remember when the name-
Watch the cartoons Tom.
... was revealed before I had a chance to
see it, I saw it on Twitter, I was like, "Why
is everyone posting about Goku.
What?
Huh?"
And then I watched it and I was like, "Oh."
I'm not falling for this trick.
His name's baby Yoda.
As he is known in my heart.
I want him to be named Yo Diddly.
Like Yoda.
And then the lady Yoda was Yaddle, from the
prequels.
Mm-mm.
The logical progression is Yo Diddly.
Everybody's favorite character from the prequels
old Yaddle.
Yaddle.
Yeah.
Super popular.
Mm-mm.
Fun fact: Started as a teenage Yoda puppet.
And then they were like, "No, that's stupid.
Just make it a girl."
So they made it a different character.
Anyway, we got off topic.
She only showed up in one movie though.
Right?
I'm pretty sure only one movie.
I think there might be some comic book stuff
about her, but very little as far as I know,
I'm not up on my Yaddle.
Baby Yoda rebuttals aside my pick is Lilo
and Stitch.
That's a really good pick because Lilo and
Stitch is a great movie that-
And that's the other thing, my second choice
was Emperor's New Groove because I wouldn't
want them to ruin it because that movie is
good.
Legitimate.
Mm-mm.
And I feel the same way about Lilo and Stitch.
I like that movie and I don't want them to
mess it up.
Because that was my pick.
My pick was The Emperor's New Groove.
Which I will briefly discuss now.
Yeah.
That was my pick.
It's one of my favorite Disney movies, because
I think it's super duper funny.
It's so funny.
And one of the reasons that it works so well
is because it's a cartoon that knows it's
a cartoon.
Right.
It really works with the form.
Yeah.
Exactly.
It's the most Warner Brothers-ie Disney movie.
Mm-mm.
It's got that spirit of the old Bugs Bunny,
Daffy Duck cartoons.
Very Chuck Jones.
Mm-mm.
Exactly very Chuck Jones.
And it's I want to say it's goofy, but that's
bringing a whole different character to this.
Right.
But there's just all this great stuff in there
that wouldn't be translated into a live action
remake.
It would be lame.
Yeah.
I would be less interested in seeing that.
I think that would be a huge bummer.
Anyway, that was one of my picks.
And I just wanted to mention it.
I have another one as a backup just in case,
but anyway.
No.
And I wasn't going to talk about Emperor's
New Groove.
But you did anyway.
You brought it up anyway.
I know.
It's called a segue, right?
I'm sorry.
No, it's okay.
But I agree with you completely.
That movie is so much fun.
Right.
And I don't want it to be completely molded
into something creepy and weird.
I think the main thing here on both of these
picks is that it's the main problem with a
lot of these live action remakes, which is
that these stories, these films work really
well because they are animated films.
Mm-mm.
And animation as a medium has a lot of strengths
that live action doesn't.
Yeah.
So when you translate it to live action, you
lose a lot.
And you introduce all these strange things
like uncanny valley objects and beast's mansion,
castle, excuse me, creepy beast face, creepy
stitch from Lilo and Stitch that we're hoping
we don't get.
And the expressiveness of characters in Lilo
and Stitch and Emperor's New Groove is really
important to both of those movies.
Yeah.
Like the facial reactions.
I watched a couple of clips of The Lion King,
because I wanted to keep sleeping at night,
but I didn't sit down for the entire film.
But I saw that the main criticism was that
there was no emotion at all on any of their
faces.
Their faces don't move, because lions faces
don't move.
Right.
And so imagine how bad Emperor's New Groove
would be if they couldn't do any funny facial
reactions.
Yeah.
Photo realistic lama.
With peanut butter on its lips.
There's a reason that the live action that
the remake of Mr. Ed didn't go anywhere.
Right.
Except straight to our hearts.
You can find it on YouTube.
It's terrifying.
The remake of Mr. Ed.
It's real bad.
Anyway, Tom.
Wait, I'm sorry.
What era was the remake of Mr. Ed?
I want to say it's late nineties.
Yeah.
There's on air pilot on YouTube that I caught
a few minutes of.
That was just really, really bad.
We were a Pachinski family, so I never really
had the opportunity.
Tom, what's your pick?
I had a hard time with this one because my
gut reaction, just in terms of, and keeping
in mind The Lion King, and I love John Favreau,
but nothing about that movie really worked.
Right.
Somehow he managed to be the only filmmaker
in history to get a small performance out
of Billy Eichner.
And arguably Beyonce.
Yeah.
And you were talking about with the characterization,
and all of the stuff that you get to do with
fantasy animation, I guess.
All of the musical numbers lost all of that
sense of wonder that you remember seeing watching
the classics.
Right.
And instead it becomes two hours of animals
walking in a straight line and reciting lyrics
to songs that you've heard before.
So my initial reaction was Fantasia.
And then I remembered that they did already
The Sorcerer's Apprentice movie during The
of Pirates of the Caribbean era of let's take
anything that we own the name to and see if
we can turn it into a PG-13.
Right.
The Haunted Mansion.
Why wouldn't this?
Yeah.
Mm-mm.
So, that was my initial reaction.
What I landed on was The Rescuers.
Mm-mm.
That's a good pick.
Good pick, I loved that movie.
I watched it so much as a kid.
The only version of it that I would want to
see is if they made it in the same way that
they made the original Rescuers, which was
they had all these terrible production issues
I think the movie got shelved for a decade
and then a new team of animators came on and
finished it.
So if you watch the movie, the first half
looks entirely different from the second half,
the main characters eyes changed shape.
Right.
And they basically turn into these completely
different creatures.
And if we wanted to do it like that, I would
be a hundred percent on board.
It was just like this social experiment art
film.
Riddled with problems.
That's what you want.
Yeah, but by design.
Would it be like, I was going to say, would
Charlie Kaufman be involved?
I don't really see a way that we could keep
him out.
So if you did A Rescuers remake starring Charlie
Day.
Mm-mm.
I'd be into that.
Okay.
Now I'm going for it, now I want it to happen.
Is he playing one of the mice or is he?
He's all the parts.
Is he using his rat stick on?
Yeah.
He's all over it.
I want to watch this movie.
I changed my mind make this one.
Charlie Day versus the rescuers.
I'm into it.
The rescuers visit Philadelphia.
The only other one that I had, I guess I had
two just in the chamber and they're obvious
ones, Hunchback of Notre Dame, how would that
work?
Yeah.
How do you make a kid's movie out of The Hunchback
of Notre Dame without animating it?
And the answer is you don't.
Well, they made several live action movies
in the past of Hunchback of Notre Dame.
And they were all really unsettling.
Right.
If Disney made a remake of their remake.
Yeah.
Because they rewrote the whole story that
you have to rewrite the ending so that it's
less horrific.
Yeah.
That would be really terrible.
And then the other one obviously is Pocahontas.
I was hoping you'd say Pocahontas.
Right.
Again, how do you Disney, the only reason
why the Disney version that exists even works
at all, if it arguably works at all is because
it's animated.
As soon as you remove the layer of unreality
and put actual actors doing these things in
there, it just, it falls apart.
Yeah.
Probably a better idea to just leave that
one alone.
Does it feel like the Pocahontas cartoon was
like a series of hundreds and hundreds of
people too afraid to say this is a bad idea
to their boss?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I was reading about the production, that one
sprang to mind.
Mm-mm.
And it sounds like the guy who was running
Disney animation at the time, had a Thanksgiving
dinner and came up with this idea.
And that was the entire origin story for this
movie.
And I just can't imagine the production process
on it because it was years, it took years
to make this right.
Right.
I'm just thinking of all of these underlings
in dark corners of the Disney animation studio
huddled around each other, going, "This is
bad, right?
Like we're not going to work again."
At no point in those many years did anyone
just go, "Wasn't Pocahontas a young teenager
who was kidnapped from her home and brought
to England?"
And died of a preventable disease because
she was taken to a whole different-
A couple of years later.
At no point did anyone just bring that actual
solid fact up instead they were like, "She's
going to paint with all the colors of the
wind."
Well, we got a raccoon and the raccoon's funny.
Silly business.
They probably went over that stuff in the
director video sequel.
Right.
I didn't watch it, but I can only assume that
they addressed these serious concerns.
As a girl who watched a lot of Pocahontas,
they did not cover any of that in the director
video sequel.
That's a shame.
Yeah.
Oh, well.
That didn't come up somehow.
Weird.
Next time.
Thanks for watching.
Please hit like and subscribe so you don't
miss a single video.